- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La séance est ouverte.
Avant de commencer,
je voudrais
vous présenter
tous mes voeux
pour cette nouvelle
année qui commence,
à vous et à vos familles.
L'ordre du jour
appelle les questions
au gouvernement.
La première d'entre
elles va être posée
par le président
Marleix pour le groupe
Les Républicains.
- Olivier Marleix:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
la seule question
que se posent
les Français à la suite
de votre nomination
à Matignon, c'est:
est-ce que ça va changer
quelque chose
pour nous?
La France connaît toujours
une dette abyssale
qui la place au bord
de la faillite.
Les Français
ont de plus en plus de mal
à boucler leurs fins de mois,
nos frontières
sont toujours des passoires,
la violence explose,
on ne peut
plus se faire soigner
dans de nombreux départements,
nos EHPAD manquent
de tout et on a désormais
une crise
du logement
sans précédent,
avec des salariés
condamnés à dormir
dans leur voiture.
Vos défis,
c'est peu de le dire,
sont immenses.
Le seul remède,
c'est d'agir avec courage,
même
quand c'est difficile,
même quand c'est impopulaire.
Nous nous sommes quittés
en décembre
sur l'adoption
de la loi immigration
qui a suscité une crise
qui a fait imploser
votre majorité,
le gouvernement
de madame Borne,
notamment sur la question
de l'Aide médicale d'Etat.
Ces aides sociales
coûtent 1,2 milliard
aux Français.
Ces mêmes Français,
vous leur demandez
de contribuer de manière
supplémentaire
de 0,50 euro de plus par boîte
de médicaments
ou ces Français
à qui vous déremboursez
un peu plus les soins dentaires.
Votre prédécesseur,
ainsi que votre ministre
de l'Intérieur,
s'était engagé
devant la représentation
nationale
à enfin réformer l'AME
pour la recentrer
sur des soins d'urgence
et des soins vitaux.
Allez-vous tenir cet engagement?
Quand allez-vous
nous présenter un projet
de loi?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
le Premier ministre.
Applaudissements
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur
le président Marleix,
c'est la première fois
que je m'exprime
dans cet hémicycle
en tant que Premier ministre.
Vous me permettrez
de commencer en remerciant
le président
de la République
pour sa confiance,
en remerciant
les membres
du gouvernement
que j'ai proposés
et que j'ai nommés
pour m'accompagner,
en remerciant
la représentation
nationale
pour son accueil parmi vous.
Monsieur le président Marleix,
en choisissant
de me nommer Premier
ministre, le président
de la République
a choisi de nommer
un ministre du précédent
gouvernement, parfaitement lucide
sur la situation
que traversent
notre pays et les Français.
Oui, notre pays traverse
de très grands défis,
comme le monde.
Oui, des Français
traversent
de très grandes difficultés.
Oui, il y a des Français
qui doutent,
il y a des Français
qui souffrent,
en colère, des Français
qui n'y croient plus.
Je ne tomberai jamais
dans le fatalisme consistant
à penser que les problèmes
des Français
ne peuvent pas être réglés,
au contraire.
Nous voyons,
chaque jour,
dans notre pays,
des Français qui innovent,
qui investissent,
qui travaillent,
qui s'engagent
dans des associations,
en solidarité
avec des Français
qui cherchent
à faire progresser
notre pays et à répondre
aux attentes
de leurs concitoyens.
Je suis l'un d'entre eux,
et les membres
de mon gouvernement
le sont également.
J'aurai l'occasion
de présenter ma déclaration
de politique générale
et nous aurons l'occasion
d'avancer sur un certain nombre
de chantiers ensemble.
Je le dis, je suis lucide
sur ces difficultés.
Je suis totalement mobilisé
pour y répondre,
notamment
celles que vous avez évoquées.
Vous avez posé
une question s'agissant
de l'immigration,
de notre modèle social
et de l'Aide médicale d'Etat.
Un texte a été
débattu au Parlement.
Un texte a été adopté.
Le Conseil constitutionnel
en est saisi
et se prononcera prochainement.
Dans le cadre
de ce texte, un débat
a eu lieu sur l'Aide
médicale d'Etat.
Ma prédécesseure
a adressé un courrier
en prenant un engagement,
et cet engagement sera tenu.
J'aurai l'occasion,
dans ma déclaration
de politique générale,
de revenir
sur les chantiers à venir,
sur la méthode
de travail.
Mais vous l'aurez compris,
je souhaite avancer vite
et fort
sur les préoccupations
de nos concitoyens
pour permettre
à notre pays d'affronter
les grands défis
qui sont devant lui.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le président?
- Olivier Marleix:
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
les beaux mots, c'est bien.
Les actions, c'est mieux.
Vous demandez
aux Français un effort
sur leurs dépenses de santé.
Ce n'est pas une raison
de ne pas passer
très vite à l'action sur l'AME.
On l'attend, en ce début d'année.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole
est à monsieur Naegelen
pour le groupe LIOT.
- Christophe Naegelen:
Au moment
où tout le monde
se souhaite des voeux
de santé, cette dernière
est la principale préoccupation
des Français, notamment
dans les territoires ruraux.
On constate un manque
de médecins
en médecine de ville.
On constate un manque
de médecins
et de personnels
soignants
dans nos hôpitaux.
C'est un constat
dans les Vosges
comme dans tout notre pays.
Ce problème prend
son origine
dans des décisions
politiques datant d'il
y a 40 ans, mais depuis 7 ans,
nos concitoyens
ne voient pas de changement.
La transformation
du numerus clausus
en numerus apertus
n'a rien changé.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre, quand,
avec la ministre
de la Santé, la ministre
de l'Enseignement supérieur,
allez-vous ouvrir
plus largement
l'accès aux études
de médecine?
Quand allez-vous
donner plus de moyens
aux universités
pour pouvoir former
plus de médecins?
De plus, monsieur
le Premier ministre,
vous avez annoncé,
lors d'un déplacement,
32 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires
pour l'hôpital.
C'est en réalité
une excellente nouvelle.
Ce chiffre,
néanmoins, est égal
à la hausse prévue et votée
de la branche maladie.
Est-ce que cette hausse
dont vous parliez
est réellement une hausse
de 32 milliards
pour notre hôpital,
pour ces personnels,
ou alors est-ce
un pur hasard
si elle correspond justement
à la hausse prévue
par la branche maladie
dans le projet
de loi de finances?
Ces 32 milliards d'euros seraient
réellement nécessaires
pour notre hôpital public.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Catherine Vautrin,
ministre du Travail,
de la Santé
et des Solidarités.
- Catherine Vautrin:
Madame la présidente,
vous avez raison,
monsieur le député Naegelen,
c'est vrai que,
depuis 40 ans,
notre pays a connu
des difficultés
en ce qui concerne
le nombre de médecins,
et bien évidemment
les personnels soignants,
vous l'avez dit vous-même, 40 ans!
Depuis 2019, nos dépenses
d'assurance maladie
ont augmenté de près de 55
milliards d'euros,
dont la moitié au bénéfice
des établissements
de santé.
En réponse à la crise
du Covid-19,
le Ségur de la santé
a apporté des réponses,
aussi bien en fonctionnement.
C'est la reconnaissance
des revalorisations salariales
pour l'ensemble
des équipes soignantes.
Mais également
des investissements,
19 milliards
d'investissements
sur la période 2020-2029.
Au-delà des chiffres,
ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est de mettre
en avant ces investissements
du quotidien.
C'est le travail
de ce que vous avez voté,
mesdames et messieurs les députés.
C'est cela que nous allons
mettre
en place, aujourd'hui,
en ayant effectivement
des hôpitaux qui seront
des hôpitaux
plus modernes, plus verts,
mais également
des investissements
qui permettront d'apporter
des réponses en matière
d'offre de soins
de qualité,
la traduction concrète
au service des bassins
de vie, au service
de nos concitoyens.
Trois maîtres
mots vont guider
cette action.
D'abord, accélérer
les investissements.
Les crédits sont là,
nous devons aller
plus vite.
Deuxièmement, concrétiser
les modernisations.
Troisièmement, donner
aux professionnels
de santé des conditions
de travail meilleures.
Voilà le chemin.
Ensemble, dans le respect
et la discussion,
nous avancerons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
- Christophe
Naegelen:
Je ne remets pas en cause
le Ségur,
qui était en réalité
une très bonne chose,
et il faut le saluer.
Je vous parle de former
plus de médecins.
C'est de ça qu'on a besoin.
Il en faut
trois pour en remplacer
un qui part en retraite.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
le président Maillard
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Sylvain Maillard: Merci.
Merci, madame la présidente.
J'associe à ma question
le président Matteï.
Je souhaite
tout d'abord, au nom
de toute la majorité
présidentielle,
saluer votre nomination
comme nouveau chef
du gouvernement,
monsieur le Premier ministre.
Applaudissements
Votre nomination est le gage d'une
volonté d'audace
et de renouvellement
que nous avons toujours incarnée
aux yeux des Français.
Fidèle à ces valeurs
et au projet
qui est le nôtre
depuis 2017,
celui du président
de la République,
vous avez exprimé
votre ambition
d'un gouvernement
centré sur l'action
et les résultats,
et ce au bénéfice
de tous les citoyens.
Les chantiers, disons-le,
sont nombreux.
En premier,
il y a bien sûr l'école
de la République,
vous en avez fait
une priorité absolue.
Nous ne pouvons
que le saluer, monsieur
le Premier ministre.
Mais il y a également
le respect
de l'autorité et du droit
de la sécurité.
Il y a aussi la défense
du pouvoir d'achat
et des classes moyennes,
la promotion
de la valeur travail,
oui, la promotion
la préservation
de notre modèle
social, la maîtrise
de nos finances
publiques
ou encore l'accélération
de la transition écologique.
Tous ces défis,
il est impératif
que nous les relevions
ensemble
si nous voulons
que la France de demain
soit fidèle
à elle-même, fidèle
à son histoire.
Dans cette perspective,
monsieur
le Premier ministre,
comment entendez-vous dérouler
votre action
pour les mois à venir?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
le Premier ministre.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Monsieur le président
Sylvain Maillard,
quand j'ai été nommé
Premier ministre,
j'ai eu l'occasion
d'indiquer
quelles étaient mes grandes
priorités.
Oui, comme vous,
je veux agir
pour tous ces Français
qui sont toujours
au rendez-vous
de leurs responsabilités,
qui travaillent
tous les jours,
qui se trouvent souvent
un peu au-dessus
pour recevoir les aides sociales.
C'est à cette France
que je veux m'adresser
et que je veux accompagner.
Oui, monsieur
le président Maillard,
je veux continuer
à m'engager pour l'école
de la République.
J'ai eu l'occasion
de fixer un cap,
de prendre
des premières décisions
pour l'Education
nationale et la jeunesse.
Ce cap sera tenu.
Nous devons remettre
de l'exigence
et de l'excellence
à tous les étages.
L'école n'est pas un tapis
roulant
sur lequel on se pose
et où on passe
de classe en classe
sans vérifier
si on a le niveau.
Remettre de l'exigence
et de l'excellence,
c'est ce que
nous devons
à tous les élèves de France
en matière d'égalité
des chances.
Nous allons agir
sur l'accès aux soins
et pour la santé
de nos concitoyens,
ce qui est une très grande
priorité.
Oui, nous allons poursuivre
notre investissement
pour la sécurité
de nos concitoyens,
pour que les droits et les devoirs
soient respectés
en tout lieu
dans la République,
pour les familles
au rendez-vous
de leurs responsabilités
et celles
de leurs enfants.
Oui, monsieur
le président Maillard,
nous allons continuer
à avancer aussi
pour la planification écologique.
C'est un immense chantier
de transformation.
Je le dis,
les résultats
que nous avons obtenus
en matière
de réduction
des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre
ces derniers mois
n'avaient pas été
connus
dans notre pays auparavant.
Le président
s'exprimera ce soir
pour affirmer un cap.
Il m'appartiendra
ensuite de présenter
devant la représentation
nationale
ma déclaration
de politique générale.
Cette déclaration
de politique générale,
je souhaite la construire
et la nourrir
avec l'ensemble des forces
politiques représentées
dans cet hémicycle et au Sénat.
Je recevrai l'ensemble des groupes
politiques représentés
au Parlement
pour construire
avec eux cette déclaration
de politique générale.
J'échangerai
avec les forces syndicales,
avec les élus locaux.
Je me déplacerai
aussi sur le terrain
pour nourrir
cette feuille de route
avec les Français.
J'ai proposé à la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale
que la déclaration
de politique générale puisse
se tenir le 30 janvier prochain.
Et ce,
après concertation
avec ceux qui sont prêts
pour relever
les défis des Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Laure Lavalette
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Laure Lavalette:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
le théâtre élyséen ferme
ses portes ce soir,
mais la nomination
de votre gouvernement
donne déjà
une idée du grand
rendez-vous promis
par Emmanuel Macron.
Laxisme judiciaire
et places de prison
non construites,
monsieur Dupond-Moretti reste
à la justice,
croissance quasi nulle
et dettes qui explosent,
monsieur Bruno
Le Maire reste à l'économie,
débâcle sécuritaire
et chaos migratoire,
monsieur Gérald Darmanin
s'auto-reconduit
au ministère de l'Intérieur.
S'ajoutent à la liste madame
Amélie Oudéa-Castéra,
félicitée
pour le mensonge du Stade
de France, ou encore monsieur
Stéphane Séjourné,
exfiltré en catastrophe
des élections européennes
et qui nous explique
qu'il est compétent
parce qu'il a vécu à l'étranger.
En voilà, un argument de poids!
Il y a pire, monsieur
le Premier ministre,
que de vouloir
tout changer
pour que rien ne change,
il y a ne rien vouloir changer
du tout, à commencer
par la politique
de saccage social,
de fiscalité étouffante
et de précarisation
généralisée
que vous menez
depuis bientôt sept ans.
Voici comment,
au milieu de l'hiver,
vous annoncez la hausse de 10%
des factures d'électricité
pour les ménages.
Une inflation
en baisse, ça reste
une inflation.
Les prix de la nourriture,
des services
et des biens continuent
à augmenter.
Voici maintenant trois ans
que les Français paient 2 euros
pour le litre d'essence.
La solution réside
dans les taxes,
qui représentent
une part démesurée
des prix à la pompe
comme de l'électricité.
Il faut d'urgence
baisser la TVA
sur les produits énergétiques,
il faut également instaurer
le taux 0 pour une centaine
de produits
de première nécessité.
Après la hausse
des trains
ou de la viande,
allez-vous prendre conscience
de la gravité de la situation
ou attendez-vous
la ruine définitive
des classes moyennes
de ce pays?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Bruno Le Maire,
ministre de l'Economie,
des Finances,
de la Souveraineté
industrielle et numérique.
- Bruno Le Maire:
Madame la députée,
le pouvoir d'achat
est un sujet
trop sérieux pour se contenter
de déclarations péremptoires.
Prenez la question
de l'électricité
et du gaz,
qui est la principale raison
de l'inflation
dans notre pays
depuis deux ans.
Cette majorité a mis
en place un bouclier
sur l'électricité et le gaz
qui a mieux protégé
la population
française
que toutes les autres
populations européennes.
Quand l'électricité
a flambé
et que la facture
d'électricité
des Français aurait dû
doubler, passant
de 1000 à 2000 euros,
nous avons pris
en charge la moitié
de cette facture,
soit 1000 euros.
Vous et votre groupe,
vous proposez
la baisse de la TVA à 5%,
ce qui aurait représenté 300 euros
d'économies.
Nous avons fait
3 fois mieux
que vous sur le pouvoir d'achat.
Je me permettrai
de vous rappeler
que nous n'aurions pas eu
de problème
de pouvoir d'achat
ni de flambée
des prix de l'électricité
et du gaz
si votre ami monsieur
Vladimir Poutine
n'avait pas attaqué l'Ukraine!
Enfin, madame Lavalette,
où étiez-vous,
où était votre groupe
quand nous avons décidé
de revaloriser
les pensions de retraite
pour suivre l'inflation?
Vous avez voté contre.
Quand nous avons décidé
de revaloriser
les minima sociaux,
vous avez voté contre.
Quand nous avons revalorisé
les revenus,
vous avez voté contre.
Vous avez voté
contre toutes les revalorisations.
Aidez-nous
dans notre combat
pour le pouvoir
d'achat des Français!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
- Laure Lavalette:
Nous referons
de la France
le paradis énergétique
qu'elle devrait
être pour la France
et les entreprises.
Vous avez éteint
la lumière,
nous la rallumerons!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame la présidente
madame Chatelain
pour le groupe écologiste.
- Cyrielle Chatelain:
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
en laissant Emmanuel
Macron s'accaparer
tous les pouvoirs,
c'est notre démocratie
qui est en danger.
Vous n'avez
entre vos mains
ni notre destin,
ni celui de la France.
Vous êtes là par le bon
vouloir du président.
Votre nomination
est le choix
de la continuité.
Rien d'étonnant,
alors que vous renoncez
à demander la confiance
de l'Assemblée nationale.
Comme madame Borne,
vous êtes condamné
à rester l'exécutant
zélé d'un président
qui s'imagine souverain,
d'un président qui,
depuis maintenant
sept ans, ne peut
que constater
la chute du soutien
des Français à sa politique.
Pourtant, de remaniement
en remaniement,
rien ne change.
De la répression
des gilets jaunes
au passage en force
de la réforme
des retraites,
du soutien des prédateurs
contre les femmes,
des menaces
contre la Ligue
des droits de l'homme
à la loi immigration,
de la promotion
du séparatisme
scolaire à l'ascension
des corrompus,
"par les riches
et pour les riches"
pourrait
être le slogan
de votre gouvernement.
Cette Assemblée
nationale est née
de la volonté
des Français de mettre
un terme aux privilèges,
du désir
de reprendre
en main le contrôle
de leur destin.
Un exécutif qui s'attaque
aux contre-pouvoirs,
qui gouverne
sans le Parlement
et qui décide de décider
sans les corps intermédiaires,
cela a un nom:
ça s'appelle un régime illibéral.
En France,
nos institutions
sont une protection.
Elles ont vocation
à s'assurer
que le président
ne décide pas seul,
qu'il décide
dans l'intérêt général
et dans l'intérêt
de tous les Français.
Alors, j'ai une seule
question:
est-ce que vous fragiliserez
notre démocratie
dans l'intérêt et le privilège
de quelques-uns?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
le Premier ministre.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Madame la présidente
Chatelain,
je vous remercie
d'avoir rappelé
ce qui fait la Constitution
de la Ve République:
c'est le président
de la République
qui nomme le Premier ministre.
Ca n'a pas changé
pendant les fêtes.
Madame la présidente,
je pourrais répondre
sur de nombreux
sujets
que vous avez évoqués.
Permettez-moi
simplement de dire
que j'ai été, et je pense
que beaucoup l'ont été ici,
heurté par un certain
nombre de termes
que vous avez employés.
Opposer la France
et la République française,
l'opposer
à la démocratie,
parler de régime
illibéral, quel mépris
pour tous
les habitants du monde
qui se battent
pour les droits de l'homme
dans des pays
où les droits de l'homme
ne sont pas garantis!
Si nous étions dans un régime
illibéral
ou dans une dictature,
vous n'auriez
même pas pu adresser
vos questions
au Premier ministre.
Vous prétendez défendre
les institutions,
mais vous les piétinez
vous-même
avec ce type de propos.
Oui, la France
est une grande démocratie.
Oui, notre pays connaît
des difficultés.
Oui, ces difficultés
se traduisent
par des débats
politiques difficiles.
Oui, nous sommes amenés
à devoir utiliser
notre Constitution,
rien que notre Constitution.
En disant
l'inverse,
vous ne respectez pas
celles
et ceux qui se battent
dans le monde
pour vivre en démocratie.
Vous donnez
une voix
à ceux qui sont les véritables
ennemis
de notre République.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
Madame la présidente?
- Cyrielle Chatelain:
Le fait
d'avoir enlevé
le président du corps dit
la vérité sur la réforme
des retraites,
la volonté
de vouloir dissoudre
les Soulèvements
de la Terre,
le fait d'assumer
de passer des lois
qui vont à l'encontre
de notre Constitution,
de nos règles communes,
de nos valeurs...
Vous ne voyez pas
la déchéance
que vous êtes en train
de provoquer!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
la présidente Panot
pour le groupe
La France Insoumise.
- Mathilde Panot:
Madame la présidente,
nos pensées
se tournent d'abord
vers nos compatriotes
réunionnais
et voisins
mauriciens, frappés
par un cyclone.
Nous leur adressons
notre entière solidarité.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre,
ceci n'est pas
un remaniement,
c'est un effondrement.
Artisan du malheur
des Français
depuis bientôt sept ans,
puis Premier ministre
depuis sept jours
d'un gouvernement
que vous n'avez pas
choisi,
vous étiez minoritaire
en 2023,
vous serez minoritaire en 2024.
Il n'a jamais été
question de changer
de cap mais de privilégier
la bourgeoisie.
Vous devez
cela à une géographie exiguë,
mais vos ministres
sont hués
jusque dans le 6e
arrondissement
de Paris.
Les instances nationales
s'inquiètent.
La France est condamnée
pour inaction climatique.
Des personnes sans abri
meurent gelées
dans la septième
puissance mondiale!
Le président dit
qu'il veut renouer
le débat avec les Français.
Qu'il commence
par augmenter les salaires
et par réquisitionner
les logements vides!
Vous avez déclaré
entrer en politique
pour soutenir Ségolène Royal.
Vous finissez par recycler
les ministres
de Nicolas Sarkozy.
Ceci n'est pas
un remaniement,
c'est un effondrement.
Vous êtes Premier
ministre,
mais le monarque gouverne seul.
Ce soir, il présentera
la politique générale
du gouvernement à votre place.
Ceci n'est pas
un remaniement,
c'est un effondrement.
Vous avez adopté
une loi immigration
avec les voix et les idées
de l'extrême droite.
Vous êtes le produit
d'une faillite morale
et idéologique!
Pour la première
fois de l'histoire,
des invertébrés politiques
sont au pouvoir!
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
allez-vous enfin respecter
le Parlement?
Comptez-vous demander
le vote de confiance,
comme tous
les Premiers ministres
depuis trois décennies?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
le Premier ministre.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Madame la présidente Panot,
nouvelle année,
nouveau Premier ministre,
nouveau gouvernement
et il y a des choses
qui ne changent pas.
Vous avez posé la question
la plus politicienne
depuis le début
de ces questions
au gouvernement.
Madame la présidente Panot,
vous choisissez
de parler de ma vie,
de mon parcours.
J'ai vu aussi
des expressions
sur celles
et ceux qui sont membres
de mon gouvernement.
Je vais vous le dire
de manière
très claire,
et cela nous différencie
manifestement,
même si vous donnez
des discours
différents,
je ne regarde pas d'où
les gens viennent,
je regarde où ils veulent aller.
Je ne regarde pas
les gens
pour ce
qu'ils sont mais pour ce
qu'ils font.
Je ne me soucierai
jamais, en regardant
mes ministres,
les parlementaires,
tous les Français
qui veulent agir,
de leur couleur de peau,
de leur origine sociale.
Je ne me soucierai jamais
de ces sujets-là.
L'important
est de vouloir agir
pour les Français.
Vous avez abordé
un sujet important
dans votre question,
qui est celui
du froid
et de nos concitoyens
qui sont sans abri.
Evidemment que c'est un sujet
qui, humainement
et socialement,
nous indigne
et pour lequel nous avons tous
à coeur d'agir.
Madame la présidente
Panot,
je vous mets
au défi de me citer
une majorité qui,
comme celle-ci,
a sorti 550.000 personnes
du sans-abrisme.
Nous avons doublé les places
d'hébergement d'urgence!
Le gouvernement a annoncé
des crédits supplémentaires
pour créer des places
d'hébergement supplémentaires
pour nos concitoyens
qui sont en difficulté
depuis quelques jours.
Oui, c'est un sujet
très difficile humainement
et socialement.
C'est un sujet sur lequel
nous allons continuer
à agir par-delà
les blocages
et les oppositions
de celles
et ceux qui ne
veulent pas
que nous réglions
les problèmes
des Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Guillaume Vuilletet
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Guillaume Vuilletet: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
Des vents à plus de 170
km/h, des milliers
de foyers privés d'eau
et d'électricité,
des milliers de personnes
déplacées: l'île
de La Réunion a frôlé le pire.
Le cyclone Belal
l'a fortement impactée.
Les dégâts
sont importants,
mais il semble
que le cataclysme
qui était au coeur
de toutes les craintes
n'a pas eu lieu.
Certes, la nature
a peut-être été épargnée
et est devenue un peu
plus clémente,
mais c'est aussi
parce que ce territoire s'est
préparé avec méthode
à affronter cet événement.
Je veux saluer l'esprit
de responsabilité
et de civisme
des Réunionnais,
l'action efficace
des services de l'Etat,
des forces de secours
et de sécurité,
des agents locaux
et de leurs élus
qui ont préparé
les mesures de protection.
Celles-ci ont permis
de préserver
au mieux des vies,
les équipements
et les biens.
Au moment où je vous parle,
il semble
qu'il y ait une victime
à déplorer.
Je veux transmettre
tout mon soutien
à sa famille et à ses proches.
Je veux aussi,
au nom de mon groupe,
vous demander de transmettre
notre salut fraternel
aux Réunionnais
que vous allez rejoindre
dès ce soir.
Je veux aussi demander
à nos collègues
de La Réunion de rester unis.
Monsieur le ministre,
le gouvernement
a décidé de mobiliser
des moyens importants
pour réparer ce qui doit
l'être, accompagner
nos compatriotes
dans leurs démarches.
Il semblerait qu'à
la demande du président
de la République
et du Premier ministre,
des renforts
de société civile,
des gendarmes et des agents
d'Enedis soient envoyés
sur place.
Je souhaite
que vous précisiez l'état
de la situation
et les détails
de ce qui va être mis
en oeuvre
pour que l'île
se relève au plus vite
après cet épisode.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député Vuilletet,
j'ai évidemment
une pensée pour l'ensemble
des Réunionnais.
Malheureusement,
nous avons découvert manifestement
deux autres corps
qui seraient
ceux de 2 sans-domicile-fixe
qui auraient refusé
un hébergement d'urgence.
Je veux m'incliner
devant leur mémoire
et saluer,
comme vous l'avez fait,
les services
de l'Etat en lien
avec les collectivités locales.
Je veux saluer le travail
du préfet local.
Grâce à son action
et à celle
de la sécurité civile,
des gendarmes
et des élus locaux,
de nombreuses vies
à La Réunion ont été sauvées.
A la demande
du président
de la République
et du Premier ministre,
je me rends ce soir
à La Réunion
pour y être demain
pour pouvoir constater
que les services
de l'Etat, Météo France
en premier, ont su
alerter à temps
cette île.
Elle a été aussi
protégée
grâce à la vigilance rouge
et au confinement décidé
par le préfet.
Grâce à ce que nous avons mis
en place,
le système a permis
à chacune et à chacun,
partout sur le territoire
de La Réunion,
de pouvoir vivre
dans des conditions dégradées
mais qui ont permis
de sauver un maximum
de vies et de biens.
Demain, je me rendrai
à plusieurs reprises auprès
des agriculteurs,
des travailleurs
et des habitants de La Réunion.
Ce sera l'occasion
pour moi aussi
de répondre à leur demande
de reconnaissance
de catastrophe naturelle
pour une partie d'entre
eux et de répondre
aux questions
des agriculteurs.
Ce sera aussi
pour moi l'occasion
de dire, au nom
du gouvernement,
que l'île Maurice a été
touchée également.
Nous allons proposer
les moyens du ministère
de l'Intérieur
en protection des biens
et des personnes à l'île Maurice.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Fabien Roussel
pour le groupe GDR.
- Fabien Roussel:
Je souhaite
à mon tour apporter
ma solidarité
la plus totale
à la population réunionnaise
et que l'on soit à côté
d'elle
en ce moment très dur qu'elle vit.
Applaudissements
"Conductrice
de car scolaire,
je fais 48 km par jour
pour me rendre
à mon travail.
Je commence à 7h
du matin, 5 jours
par semaine.
Je gagne à peine plus que le RSA.
Je n'ai pas droit
à la prime d'activité
car mon conjoint
est agriculteur,
avec des revenus trop élevés
et je dois faire
mon plein pour aller travailler.
Mon salaire: 687,67 euros."
"Je suis salarié d'une
entreprise textile
à Saint-Etienne.
J'ai 34 ans d'ancienneté.
Heureusement que ma fille
de 27 ans vit
avec moi et m'aide
financièrement."
Monsieur le Premier
ministre, voilà
deux exemples
parmi des centaines
que nous recevons
depuis que le Parti Communiste
Français a lancé
une campagne
sur les salaires
et a demandé aux salariés
de leur envoyer
leurs fiches de paye.
C'est un déferlement
plein d'émotion
mais aussi de colère.
Les Français placent
depuis des années
la question du pouvoir d'achat,
de l'inflation
en tête
de toutes leurs préoccupations,
et on les comprend.
Tout augmente,
hormis les salaires,
hormis le SMIC.
En plus, aujourd'hui,
vous voulez
encore augmenter le prix
de l'électricité
au 1er février.
Tout ça, c'est le fruit
de votre politique.
C'est celle
d'une caste
qui a très bien servi
les plus riches
et qui a attaqué
nos acquis sociaux,
comme la retraite.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre, les Français
de l'Hexagone
comme de l'outre-mer
ne demandent pas l'aumône.
Ils veulent
de la justice sociale,
et c'est ce que nous proposons.
Indexer des salaires
sur l'inflation,
diviser par 3 les prix
de l'électricité
grâce au nucléaire
et investir
dans des services
publics comme l'école
et la santé également.
Allez-vous enfin changer de cap?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire:
Monsieur le député Roussel,
je vous rejoins totalement
sur la nécessité
d'avoir de meilleures
rémunérations
pour tous les salariés
de notre pays.
La première
condition pour cela,
je pense
que vous me rejoindrez,
c'est qu'il y ait
le maximum de salariés.
L'une des grandes
réussites
de cette majorité,
c'est d'avoir augmenté
le nombre de salariés en ayant
le taux d'emploi
le plus élevé
depuis 40 ans
dans notre pays.
C'est la première
condition: il faut
des salariés
pour avoir des salaires.
La deuxième chose,
c'est de protéger
les rémunérations
de ceux qui ont le salaire
le plus faible, le SMIC.
Là, je suis en désaccord
avec vous.
S'il y a une rémunération
qui a beaucoup augmenté
au cours
des deux dernières années,
c'est le SMIC
qui a augmenté
de plus de 10%,
parce que nous sommes dans le seul
pays où il est indexé
sur l'inflation
et sur la moyenne des salaires.
Troisième chose:
votez avec nous l'augmentation
de la prime
d'activité, votez
avec nous la prime
Macron défiscalisée
qui a profité à 5
millions de salariés
pour une moyenne
de près de 700 euros
par an pour les salariés.
Votez avec nous ce que vous
avez toujours refusé
et qui est pourtant une mesure
de justice fondamentale
pour tous
les ouvriers
et pour tous les salariés:
la défiscalisation
des heures
supplémentaires
qui fait
plus de rémunération
pour tous ceux qui travaillent.
Nous protégeons les plus modestes.
J'ai rappelé
tout à l'heure
que nous avions fait
le choix,
avec le président
et le Premier ministre,
d'indexer l'ensemble
des prestations sociales
et l'ensemble
des minima sociaux
sur l'inflation.
J'ai fait
le choix hier,
alors qu'il m'était
proposé de baisser
d'un peu plus de 4,5%
la rémunération
de l'épargne
populaire, de mettre
cette rémunération à 5%
pour que l'épargne
des plus modestes
soit supérieure
à l'inflation.
Enfin, il faut recréer
de la dynamique salariale.
Nous y sommes prêts
et nous y travaillons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
le président Marcangeli
pour le groupe Horizons.
- Laurent Marcangeli:
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
le groupe Horizons
et apparentés tient
à saluer
votre nomination
ainsi que celle
de votre gouvernement.
Je souhaite également
saisir cette occasion
pour saluer l'ensemble
du travail effectué
pendant 20 mois
par votre prédécesseure,
madame la Première ministre
Elisabeth Borne.
Je le dis
sans triomphalisme,
nous avons pris
des décisions
que les circonstances
exigeaient,
dans le sens de l'intérêt général.
Nous en sommes convaincus,
la majorité présidentielle doit
être au rendez-vous
des espoirs
et des attentes
de nos concitoyens.
Il faut faire
des années qui viennent
un temps utile pour la France.
Partenaires sérieux,
partenaires loyaux
mais partenaires
exigeants:
c'est ainsi que nous concevons
d'accompagner
votre action.
C'est pourquoi
notre détermination demeure
sans faille.
Notre groupe fera
preuve de constance
dans la suite de nos débats
parlementaires,
en restant attentifs
à la poursuite
du débat engagé
sur les grandes priorités
de notre temps.
Citons l'excellence
à l'école, afin
que chaque jeune ait les moyens
de réaliser pleinement
son potentiel, la réforme
de notre système
de santé,
avec notamment la lutte
contre les déserts médicaux,
la revalorisation
du travail afin
que celui-ci paie
pour toute personne
qui contribue
à l'effort productif
de notre pays,
le maintien d'une politique
économique ambitieuse
qui ne perd pas de vue
la baisse
des déficits tout en étant
garant d'attractivité,
de compétitivité
et donc de prospérité.
La transition écologique,
sous l'autorité
de monsieur
le ministre Béchu,
ainsi que la transition
énergétique
sont importantes.
Les thématiques
que je viens de citer
sont cruciales.
Pouvez-vous nous indiquer
comment celles-ci
vont trouver leur place
dans la politique menée
par votre gouvernement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
le Premier ministre.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Monsieur le président
Marcangeli,
je vous remercie
pour votre question
et l'état d'esprit
qui est le vôtre,
comme celui des groupes
MoDem et Renaissance,
de la majorité
présidentielle,
qui consiste à se poser
une question
qui peut
paraître simple,
mais qui me semble être le b.a-ba.
Quelles sont les attentes
concrètes
de nos concitoyens
et comment pouvons-nous
y répondre?
Vous avez abordé
les attentes profondes
de nos concitoyens,
faire que le travail paie
plus et que travailler
soit toujours
plus intéressant
que ne pas travailler.
Ca paraît là aussi
une forme de base,
mais malheureusement,
je constate régulièrement
que ça ne l'est pas
pour tout le monde
et que pour d'autres,
il s'agit
d'un objectif annexe.
C'est le travail
qui crée la richesse
et qui nous permet de financer
les services publics
et la solidarité.
C'est le travail
qui nous permet
de redistribuer,
qui nous permet d'investir
dans les services publics.
Certains manient la taxe
et l'impôt supplémentaire
comme un préalable
à toute chose,
et en faisant cela,
ils nuiraient
à la compétitivité
de notre pays,
au travail dans notre pays.
Nous sommes alignés
de ce point de vue-là.
Sur les services
publics majeurs
que constituent
l'école et la santé,
oui, ce sont des priorités
absolues
pour lesquelles
nous allons accélérer.
J'aurai l'occasion
d'y revenir
dans ma déclaration
de politique générale
après avoir rencontré
l'ensemble
des groupes parlementaires
et les organisations syndicales.
J'indiquerai
comment avancer
avec vous sur ces sujets.
Sur la planification
écologique,
grâce à Christophe
Béchu,
nous avons depuis plusieurs
mois
une planification
qui a été dressée
par le président
de la République,
par la Première ministre.
Nous allons
continuer à faire
de la France
une nation en Europe
qui s'engage
encore plus que les autres
sur la transition écologique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Valérie Bazin-Malgras.
- Valérie Bazin-Malgras:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
vous venez d'annoncer 32 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires
pour le système
de santé.
C'était une annonce spectaculaire.
Mais en réalité,
ces 32 milliards d'euros
ne sont pas nouveaux
et ont déjà été votés.
Au vu de la situation
de notre système
de santé,
on ne peut pas jouer
avec l'ensemble
des acteurs du monde
de la santé en leur jetant
de la poudre
aux yeux.
Vous ne faites
qu'accroître le désarroi
de notre personnel
soignant,
à qui je veux rendre hommage.
Car oui, la réalité
de la France
de 2024,
c'est que l'hôpital
est en crise
et que nos EHPAD
sont dans une situation
financière dramatique.
Les personnels
soignants,
malgré leur dévouement
et leur travail,
sont à bout de souffle.
Ils sont trop souvent débordés.
Ce sont les résidents
et leurs familles
qui en payent le prix fort.
Sur tous les territoires,
les EHPAD
sont au bord de l'asphyxie
financière, incapables
de boucler leur budget.
A l'heure du vieillissement
de la population,
votre gouvernement
doit faire
de la question
de l'autonomie
et du grand âge
une priorité
pour notre pays.
Depuis 2017,
le président Macron
nous promet le financement
de la cinquième branche
de la Sécurité sociale,
et nous ne voyons
toujours rien venir.
Alors, contrairement
à vos prédécesseurs,
allez-vous enfin
être le Premier ministre
des promesses tenues?
Il y a urgence
à ce que vous répondiez rapidement
aux demandes
de nos hôpitaux
et de nos EHPAD.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Catherine Vautrin.
- Catherine Vautrin:
Madame la députée
Valérie Bazin-Malgras,
votre question
est évidemment
l'occasion de répondre
aux professionnels
de santé
en leur rendant hommage
pour leurs compétences
et leur engagement.
Qu'ils soient libéraux
ou hospitaliers, d'ailleurs.
Effectivement,
l'hôpital,
c'est notre trésor
national,
et nous allons très concrètement
investir massivement
pour l'hôpital accélérer
ces investissements.
Les crédits sont là.
Il y a une seconde,
vous faisiez allusion
à des crédits votés.
Je pense que nous allons
nous retrouver
sur le fait
que c'est bien de voter
des crédits,
mais c'est encore mieux
de les dépenser.
L'enjeu aujourd'hui,
c'est très concrètement
d'accélérer
cette démarche
pour que ces crédits
deviennent réalité,
que nos établissements de santé,
hospitaliers, médico-sociaux,
voient l'évolution.
Ce sont les chiffres
que j'ai déclinés
tout à l'heure.
Je voudrais rappeler
l'importance
de la coopération
entre les professionnels.
Nous l'avons vu avec monsieur
le Premier ministre
à Dijon samedi,
où nous avons visité
des urgences pédiatriques
qui venaient
d'être refaites.
Quelque part,
c'est le secret d'un système
de santé qui soit à l'échelle
du bassin
de vie.
Ce que vous venez de décrire,
ce n'est rien d'autre
que l'attente
de nos concitoyens,
qu'ils soient en ville
ou dans la ruralité.
Ma feuille
de route au bout
de trois jours
est extrêmement claire.
Je vous le dis
très calmement,
madame la députée.
Vociférer ne sert à rien.
L'objectif,
c'est de garantir une offre
de soins dans tous
les bassins de vie
à chacun.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Madame la députée?
- Valérie Bazin-Malgras:
Madame la ministre,
j'ai bien entendu votre réponse.
Vous nous avez fait part
de votre feuille
de route.
Maintenant, allez-y.
Vous avez les clés,
vous avez le budget,
donc on vous attend,
pour nos EHPAD
et pour nos hôpitaux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est au président
Boris Vallaud
pour le groupe socialiste.
- Boris Vallaud:
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
vous vous présentez
devant nous après la loi
immigration, grave et coupable
faillite politique
et morale, normalisant
l'extrême droite
et ses idées.
Vous vous présentez
devant nous avec
un gouvernement
qui fait figure d'aveu,
fin du "En même temps"
et cohabitation assumée
avec la droite dure.
Après la préférence
nationale, voici
la préférence Sarkozy.
Vous vous présentez
devant nous avec
un gouvernement incomplet.
Où sont les ministres
du Logement,
de la Fonction publique?
Vous vous présentez
devant nous avec un ministre
de la Famille
qui a combattu le mariage
pour tous et s'est
opposée à la protection
de l'IVG.
Avec une ministre
de l'Education
qui méprise
l'école publique
et ses professeurs,
avec une ministre
de la Culture
dont tous les votes
à la Ville de Paris
témoignent
du peu d'intérêt
qu'elle porte
à la culture populaire.
Vous vous présentez
devant nous avec une ministre mis
en examen et la part des femmes
au gouvernement réduite
à la portion congrue.
Vous vous présentez
devant nous sans avoir prononcé
votre déclaration
de politique générale,
attendant
que le président
de la République
donne son interview
et ses instructions,
au mépris du gouvernement.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre, êtes-vous
le chef du gouvernement?
Etes-vous le chef
de la majorité,
de quelle majorité?
Etes-vous responsable
devant la représentation
nationale?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
Ah...
Vous avez terminé?
Monsieur le Premier ministre.
Comme vous preniez
une deuxième feuille,
j'ai cru que vous alliez
continuer.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Boris Vallaud...
Président Boris Vallaud.
Je rectifie mon propos
de tout à l'heure.
C'est vous qui avez posé
la question
la plus politicienne
depuis le début
de cette séance.
Vous décrochez
pour ça la médaille d'or
que Mathilde Panot
avait jusqu'à maintenant.
Monsieur le président
Boris Vallaud, j'assume
totalement...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
S'il vous plaît!
- Gabriel Attal:
J'assume totalement
d'avoir considéré
depuis 2017,
et de continuer
à le faire, que face
aux défis que rencontre
notre pays, face
aux difficultés
que traversent les Français,
nous devons nous retrousser
les manches
avec des personnes qui viennent
d'horizons politiques différents.
Et moi, je le dis
et je l'assume aussi
de manière très claire,
vous me reprochez
mon gouvernement
et des personnalités
qui font partie
de ce gouvernement.
Moi, je vais vous dire
que je préfère travailler
avec Rachida Dati
et Catherine Vautrin qu'avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
Cela nous différencie.
Nous n'avons pas les mêmes
valeurs,
pas les mêmes objectifs.
Chacun ses priorités,
chacun les personnalités
avec lesquelles
on souhaite s'associer.
Pour le reste, je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure,
l'important
pour moi,
ce n'est pas de regarder
d'où viennent
les uns et les autres,
c'est de garantir
qu'ils veulent aller
dans la même direction,
et c'est le cas de cette équipe
gouvernementale
et de cette majorité.
L'important
pour moi,
ce n'est pas de demander
à mes ministres
de vider leurs poches
pour regarder
quelle est la carte
du parti politique
dans lequel
ils étaient parfois
il y a plusieurs années.
L'important,
c'est de regarder
ce qu'ils ont dans le ventre
et ce
qu'ils ont envie
de faire
pour notre pays.
Je l'assume totalement.
L'important,
ça n'est pas de se jeter
des anathèmes
à la figure,
encore une fois.
L'important,
ça n'est pas d'enfermer
les uns et les autres
dans des positions
qu'ils ont pu tenir.
Encore heureux
qu'il y ait des Français
qui puissent changer d'avis.
Il y en a eu des millions
qui ont changé d'avis,
sur un certain
nombre de débats
que vous avez évoqués.
Ca s'appelle la démocratie,
la liberté
de conscience.
C'est un trésor pour notre pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le président?
- Boris Vallaud:
Vous avez un cap:
à droite toute.
Vous êtes la gauche
"en peau de lapin",
comme disait Clemenceau.
Voici quelques suggestions:
rétablissez l'ISF,
gelez les tarifs
de l'électricité,
rétablissez
les postes
que vous avez supprimés
dans l'Education nationale,
pour que votre ministre
consente peut-être
à y inscrire ses enfants.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Sandrine Josso.
Applaudissements nourris
...
- Sandrine Josso: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs
les ministres, chers collègues,
c'est avec beaucoup
d'émotion
que je reviens
parmi vous aujourd'hui.
Je tiens à tous
vous remercier
pour votre soutien,
et particulièrement vous,
madame la présidente.
Le 14 novembre dernier,
je suis allée
chez un ami le coeur
léger pour fêter
sa réélection.
J'en suis ressortie terrorisée.
J'ai découvert un agresseur.
Je comprends
alors que j'ai été droguée
à mon insu.
C'est ce qu'on appelle
la soumission chimique.
Ce fait de société
est un fléau
qui fait des milliers
de victimes,
du berceau à l'EHPAD,
de la boîte
de nuit à la soirée entre amis.
Tout se trouve
dans votre armoire
à pharmacie.
9 fois sur 10,
la victime est une femme,
et dans 70% des cas,
elle subira
une agression sexuelle.
Aujourd'hui,
je ne vous parle pas
en tant que femme
victime,
mais en tant que députée
de la nation
qui s'indigne
que ce sujet
ne soit pas pris à bras-le-corps.
Applaudissements
...
J'en appelle
le gouvernement,
et plus particulièrement
vous, madame
la ministre.
La France
est grande
quand elle est juste.
C'est un slogan
des années 90
qui a toute son actualité
aujourd'hui.
Le collectif
M'endors pas a interpellé
à l'automne dernier
les pouvoirs publics
pour que la lutte
contre la soumission chimique
fasse l'objet
d'un travail conjoint,
car ces violences
sont devenues
à la fois des questions
d'ordre public,
de santé, de justice
et d'éducation.
Alors, madame la ministre,
que répondez-vous
à leur cri du coeur?
Seriez-vous d'accord
pour mettre
les moyens de l'Etat
au service du combat
contre ce phénomène?
Pour mieux le cerner
et enfin trouver
le moyen de sortir
toutes les victimes
de l'oubli?
Je compte sur vous.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
Applaudissements
La parole est à madame
Aurore Bergé.
- Aurore Bergé:
Madame la députée Sandrine Josso,
et permettez-moi
de vous dire chère Sandrine.
Merci pour votre courage,
d'abord,
le courage de vous lever
dans cet hémicycle
et le courage
de parler, le courage
de témoigner
et de vous exposer,
le courage surtout de faire
de ce combat
non pas juste
le vôtre,
mais celui qui doit
être celui
de toute notre société,
car c'est désormais
un combat
dont vous vous êtes emparé
et dont vous voyez
que l'ensemble
de cet hémicycle s'est emparé.
Les droits des femmes
méritent des combattants
et des combattantes.
Je crois
que vous êtes résolument
une de ses combattantes.
La question
que vous soulevez
de la soumission
chimique est un sujet
qui ne mérite
nulle polémique,
mais qui mérite
une mobilisation
de la société tout entière.
Pendant trop longtemps,
nous avons cru
que la soumission chimique,
c'était uniquement
ce qui pouvait arriver
au détour d'une soirée.
C'était du GHB servi
dans un verre.
Ce que vous avez traversé,
cela peut arriver
dans la plus parfaite intimité.
Ca peut être un compagnon,
ça peut
être un conjoint,
ça peut être un parent,
ça peut être prétendument un ami.
La loi a changé.
Le garde des Sceaux
en est le garant,
de manière
à ce que toutes les victimes
soient considérées.
Depuis la loi
de 2018, c'est bien
un fait aggravant
pour la question
du viol, et c'est même
devenu un délit
à part entière.
Mais oui,
nous devons aller
plus loin pour mobiliser
l'ensemble
de la société,
pour mieux former,
pour mieux accompagner
les victimes,
parce que les dégâts
psychologiques peuvent perdurer
des semaines, voire
des années après,
au travers de l'amnésie
traumatique.
Pendant trop longtemps,
nous n'avons
pas écouté les femmes
lorsqu'elles parlaient.
Aujourd'hui,
nous les écoutons
et nous les croyons,
nous sommes à leurs côtés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Alexandre Loubet.
- Alexandre Loubet: Merci.
Au nom du groupe
du Rassemblement National,
permettez-moi
d'avoir une pensée
pour nos compatriotes
réunionnais
en ces jours difficiles.
Ma question s'adressait
initialement
au ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères,
qui brille malheureusement
par son absence
en ce premier jour
de séance de questions
au gouvernement.
Je vous interroge
donc, monsieur
le Premier ministre.
Vous avez nommé
Stéphane Séjourné
à la tête du Quai
d'Orsay pour défendre
les intérêts de notre pays.
Pourtant, les Français
doivent savoir
que le 22 novembre 2023
au Parlement européen,
monsieur Stéphane
Séjourné a appelé
à la fin de notre souveraineté
nationale
en votant pour un rapport.
Par ce vote symbolique
de votre ministre
et de vos députés,
vous soutenez
la mise en place
d'un président,
d'un gouvernement
et d'une armée
pour l'Union Européenne.
Vous voulez soumettre
notre droit national
à l'arbitraire
des juges européens.
Vous souhaitez
renforcer les pouvoirs
de l'Union Européenne
au détriment
des Etats en matière
de santé, d'écologie,
de sécurité,
de défense
ou encore de politique étrangère.
Et surtout, par ce vote,
vous voulez mettre fin
à la règle de l'unanimité,
dernier garant
de notre souveraineté
au Conseil européen.
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
vous voulez donc priver
la France de son droit
de veto qui, pourtant,
nous protège de toute décision
qui porterait atteinte
à nos intérêts vitaux.
Par ce vote,
votre gouvernement dévoile
son intention.
Il dévoile l'intention
d'Emmanuel Macron
de dissoudre la France
dans un Etat fédéral européen.
Ma question est donc simple:
comment prétendez-vous vouloir
représenter et défendre
notre pays,
alors qu'il y a deux mois
seulement,
votre ministre
des Affaires étrangères
a voté pour la disparition
de la France?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Loubet, j'avoue
être un peu étonnée.
Je ne sais pas
trop à qui je m'adresse
aujourd'hui.
Est-ce que je m'adresse
au député
ou au directeur
de campagne d'un homme
en campagne en ce moment?
Parlons des votes.
Je pourrais parler
en long et en large
de vos votes au sein
de cet hémicycle.
J'ai été plus haut
dans cet hémicycle.
L'incompétence règne
parmi vos rangs.
Parlons de vos votes
au niveau de l'Europe.
Vous votez contre les soutiens
à l'Europe.
Vous votez contre le fait
de dénoncer
la mainmise
en ce moment de Poutine
sur l'attaque
qu'il est en train de mener
contre l'Ukraine.
Vous votez contre le projet
qui permet
de défendre nos frontières
européennes
avec le pacte asile et migration.
Mais tout ça,
vous ne le savez pas,
et je ne peux pas vous en vouloir.
La raison est simple:
la personne
pour laquelle
vous faites campagne
en ce moment est bien
plus souvent
en train de faire
campagne pour elle-même
que pour travailler
pour les Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le député?
- Alexandre Loubet:
Madame la ministre,
vos accusations sont fausses.
Le 9 juin, aux élections
européennes,
les Français bloqueront
votre projet fédéraliste.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame Charlotte
Parmentier-Lecocq.
- Charlotte
Parmentier-Lecocq:
Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
du Travail, de la Santé
et des Solidarités.
Je tiens tout d'abord
à vous féliciter
pour votre nomination
à la tête
de ce grand ministère.
En tant que présidente
de la commission
des Affaires sociales,
je me réjouis
de notre collaboration
sur ce sujet majeur
qui touche
en profondeur la vie
de nos concitoyens.
Depuis près de 50 ans,
grâce au courage
de Simone Veil,
les femmes en France
ont le droit de disposer
de leur corps
et de faire le choix d'une
interruption volontaire
de grossesse.
Je veux ici saluer
les professionnels
qui les accompagnent.
C'est un droit fondamental.
Je remercie
le président
de la République d'avoir pris
la décision forte
de protéger ce droit
en l'inscrivant
dans la Constitution.
Vous savez que notre majorité
est extrêmement engagée
à la préservation
de ce droit
et à en garantir
l'effectivité
pour toutes les femmes.
Je rappellerai
que c'est notre majorité
qui a allongé le délai
légal de l'IVG
de 12 à 14 semaines.
C'est notre majorité
qui a élargi l'accès
à l'IVG médicamenteuse
et étendu
les compétences
des sages-femmes
pour pratiquer des IVG
instrumentales.
Madame la ministre,
l'engagement
des professionnels
est une condition sine qua
non pour garantir
la réalité de ce droit
et une juste reconnaissance
est attendue
de leur part.
Or, depuis 2016,
les tarifs de l'IVG
n'ont pas été revalorisés
et ne reflètent
plus la réalité des coûts.
Aussi, je souhaite
savoir quelles mesures
vous entendez prendre
pour remédier
à cette situation et réaffirmer
la reconnaissance
des professionnels
pour garantir l'accès
à l'IVG pour toutes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Catherine Vautrin.
- Catherine Vautrin:
Madame la députée
Parmentier-Lecocq,
à mon tour de rendre hommage
à Simone Veil.
La loi aura 49 ans demain.
C'est une loi du 17 février 1975.
Vous avez tout à fait
raison,
il est absolument
important
que nous puissions accompagner
les professionnels
qui se sont engagés
dans cette démarche.
Votre question
est extrêmement précise,
je vais vous répondre
de manière
tout aussi précise.
Dans les toutes prochaines
semaines, j'ose
à peine dire
les prochains jours,
nous allons mettre en place
la revalorisation
des tarifs de l'IVG de 25%.
Les choses sont claires.
D'autre part,
je veux en profiter
pour dire combien,
avec mon collègue,
le garde des Sceaux,
nous allons travailler
avec l'ensemble
des parlementaires,
et ce sera
notre honneur
que d'être celui
et celle qui auront
la responsabilité
d'inscrire le droit
à l'avortement
dans le marbre
de notre Constitution.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Rodrigo Arenas.
- Rodrigo Arenas: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
de l'Enseignement privé.
J'ai bataillé
durant des années
pour que l'école
publique et laïque donne
à nos enfants,
à tous nos enfants,
le meilleur
de ce que la République peut
leur offrir.
Mes combats,
je les ai menés aux côtés
de milliers
d'autres parents
que vous avez méprisés,
insultés
en quelques déclarations.
Vous vous êtes simplement
moquée
de ces élèves
et de leurs parents
qui voient chaque année
des centaines d'heures
d'enseignement disparaître,
en prétendant
avoir subi un "paquet
d'heures non remplacées"
en petite section
de maternelle, située
dans l'un des quartiers
les plus huppés
de Paris.
Toutes ces militantes
et tous ces militants
de l'école publique,
toutes celles
et ceux qui n'ont pas fait
le choix
de la réseaucratie
méritent mieux.
Manifestement, vous,
vous avez manqué d'à-propos.
Donc ma question est simple:
quand allez-vous clore
ce chapitre?
Quand allez-vous démissionner?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Amélie Oudéa-Castéra.
- Amélie Oudéa-Castéra: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Rodrigo Arenas,
à peine nommée ministre
de l'Education nationale,
j'ai été interpellée
par Mediapart
sur les choix
de scolarisation
de mes enfants.
J'ai voulu y répondre
sans esquiver l'attaque.
Je l'ai fait avec sincérité.
Je n'aurais pas dû
me laisser entraîner
sur le terrain
de la vie privée,
ni me sentir obligée
de me justifier.
Aucun parent d'élève
ne devrait l'être.
Je n'aurais pas dû
non plus exposer l'école Littré.
Je suis allée
à leur rencontre ce matin
pour m'en excuser
et m'excuser
de les avoir blessés.
Ces excuses, je les leur devais.
Depuis vendredi,
j'ai tout entendu:
les leçons de morale
de l'école publique
de la part
de ceux qui mettent
leurs enfants en école
privée, l'agressivité
de ceux qui rêveraient
de raviver
une guerre
entre l'école publique
et l'école privée,
guerre qui n'existera pas.
Ce week-end,
c'est les valeurs éducatives
de maman qui ont même
été mises en doute.
Dans mes propos
de vendredi,
je me suis appuyée
sur le souvenir
et le ressenti d'une
expérience d'il
y a 15 ans,
où notre famille,
oui, a buté sur des problèmes
d'organisation,
comme nous avons pu
nous en souvenir
avec l'enseignante
de l'époque,
avec qui j'ai échangé.
Alors maintenant, avançons.
J'ai de l'ambition pour l'école.
Je veux soutenir
toute la communauté éducative
pour remettre
l'ascenseur social
en marche.
Je veux faire
grandir le mérite
et le talent.
C'est le sens
du choc des savoirs
et de l'exigence voulue
par le Premier ministre
et les concertations
engagées
pour le métier de professeur.
Ce matin, j'ai échangé
avec les enseignants
de Littré.
Nous avons commencé à traiter
la problématique
des remplacements.
Nous irons
jusqu'au bout
et c'est un problème
que des millions
de familles veulent
que nous traitions.
C'est en ce sens que je ferai
des propositions
au Premier ministre.
L'école est la mère
des batailles,
et je mesure
l'honneur qui m'est
fait de la servir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur Rodrigo Arenas?
- Rodrigo Arenas:
Madame, cette affaire
que vous avez mise
sur la place publique
n'est pas une affaire privée.
C'est une affaire
publique qui remet
en question
la fonction même
que vous tenez.
Entre les propos
que vous avez tenus
en tant que ministre
et non pas
en tant que mère
de famille,
parce que vous avez le droit
de choisir l'école
que vous souhaitez,
et les propos
de cette enseignante
qui n'a pas manqué d'heures
de cours, j'ai choisi mon camp.
J'ai choisi celui
des enseignants
qui mettent
plus que leur salaire
pour honorer le service public
de l'Education nationale.
Redonnez à l'Education
nationale
ses lettres de noblesse!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Pierre Pont.
- Jean-Pierre Pont: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Christophe Béchu,
ministre de la Transition
écologique
et de la Cohésion des territoires.
Vous avez accompagné
mardi dernier,
quelques heures
après sa nomination,
le Premier ministre
Gabriel Attal
dans le Pas-de-Calais,
et je l'en remercie
très sincèrement,
pour apporter le soutien
de la nation aux sinistrés
des inondations.
Depuis des semaines,
nous connaissons
des épisodes pluvieux
intenses, provoquant
des inondations
exceptionnelles,
touchant plus de 200 communes,
2000 habitations,
une centaine de PME,
une cinquantaine d'exploitations
agricoles.
Tous les moyens
de pompage, nationaux
et européens,
étaient opérationnels
dès le 6 janvier,
mais la décrue
est très lente.
Le président Emmanuel Macron
avait annoncé
une première indemnisation de 50
millions d'euros
pour aider les communes
à reconstruire
des équipements publics.
En commission
des Affaires européennes,
nous avons également adopté
un avis politique visant
à solliciter le fonds
de solidarité européen.
Les sinistrés de tous
ces événements catastrophiques
attendent
des réponses précises
sur les dédommagements possibles:
franchise, perte d'exploitation
pour le commerçant,
PME et agriculteurs.
Le Premier ministre
vient d'annoncer
en faveur des sinistrés
des Hauts-de-France
le lancement d'un plan
de résilience.
Je vous serais
reconnaissant
de bien vouloir
nous en détailler
le contenu.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Jean-Pierre Pont,
oui, notre solidarité
va aux Réunionnais,
mais elle continue d'aller
au Pas-de-Calais,
où la décrue
est extrêmement lente.
Le gouvernement
est entièrement mobilisé
sur ce sujet.
J'associerai Marc Fesneau
pour les calamités agricoles,
Bruno Le Maire au titre
des franchises d'assurance
et Gérald Darmanin au titre
de la reconnaissance
de la catastrophe naturelle.
200 communes
ont été reconnues
deux fois en l'espace
de deux mois victimes
de catastrophes naturelles.
Il y a d'abord
le temps de l'urgence.
Dès hier,
des travaux de curages
ont commencé.
Dès hier, des travaux
ont été lancés.
Tout un plan a été lancé
et il aboutira début février
sur la modification
des règles concernant
les curage dans notre pays.
Il faut aussi se préoccuper
du moyen terme.
Le moyen terme,
ça a été le premier acte
administratif de notre nouveau
Premier ministre.
Le premier document
qu'il a signé,
c'est cette mission
sur un plan résilience
qui vise trois objets.
Le premier:
comment,
quand on a des territoires
à cheval
sur deux départements,
on fait
pour avoir un seul coordinateur.
Le deuxième: comment
modifier le plan
de prévention des risques
et des inondations.
Il y a peut-être
des territoires où,
à terme, on ne pourra
plus habiter.
C'est le sens
de ce plan résilience,
en mobilisant les moyens.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le député?
- Jean-Pierre Pont:
La population
ne veut plus de projets,
de promesses
ou d'études.
Elle veut de l'action,
de l'action,
de l'action, comme l'a dit
le Premier ministre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Mathilde Paris.
- Mathilde Paris: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
du Travail, de la Santé
et des Solidarités.
Fin 2020, le hashtag "Balance
ton stage" révélait
les bizutages
des étudiants infirmiers.
Bien que ces pratiques
soient interdites,
malgré l'émoi suscité par tous
les témoignages d'étudiants
infirmiers il y a trois ans,
aujourd'hui, rien n'a changé.
Laure, Amélie, Sarah:
derrière ces noms,
ce sont des vies
et des destins brisés.
Elles avaient toutes
les trois en commun
de vouloir exercer
un métier qui mettait
au centre l'humain
et dont la France
a cruellement besoin.
Peu avant Noël,
au cours de son stage
à l'hôpital, Amélie
a fait une tentative
de suicide.
Elle ne supportait
plus l'humiliation permanente,
l'inhumanité
avec laquelle
elle était traitée,
la charge excessive
de travail, incompatible
avec des soins
de qualité.
Laure, en stage
dans un centre hospitalier,
vient de découvrir que son service
dispose d'une cagnotte
à remporter
par celui qui arriverait
à la faire pleurer en premier.
Quant à Sarah,
elle a fait un burn-out
en plein stage.
Entre 2019 et 2022,
un tiers des étudiants infirmiers
a abandonné
ses études avant la fin
du cursus.
Une étude du Journal
du Dimanche réalisée
il y a un an révèle que 75%
des étudiants infirmiers
se disent épuisés physiquement.
33% confirment faire
des crises d'angoisse.
26% estiment être en mauvaise
santé psychique.
Pour tenir, 28%
des sondés ont pris
ou prennent des psychotropes.
Que comptez-vous
faire pour mettre
un terme définitif
à ces pratiques
qui se répètent
et dont les victimes d'hier
deviennent les bourreaux
de demain?
Notre système de santé
a besoin d'infirmières
et infirmiers.
Nous devons prendre soin
de nos étudiants
pour qu'ils puissent
être à leur tour
les soignants de demain.
Notre système de santé
a besoin de moyens
et pas de fake news.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Catherine Vautrin.
- Catherine Vautrin:
Madame la députée Mathilde Paris,
ce que vous venez de décrire
est évidemment totalement
inacceptable.
Personne dans cet
hémicycle ne dira
le contraire.
Maintenant,
l'engagement infirmier
à l'échelle du bassin de vie
est indispensable.
Il est aussi bien
indispensable à l'hôpital
que dans nos structures
médico-sociales.
Notre sujet,
c'est l'offre de santé
à proximité au service de tous.
A partir de là,
vous avez raison,
nous avons pris
des mesures salariales
lors du Ségur de la santé.
Nous avons actuellement
deux chantiers:
celui sur la refondation
du métier,
celui sur la rénovation
de la formation.
Il faut regarder
la manière
dont les stages se passent,
et particulièrement
en milieu hospitalier.
Je voudrais rappeler
qu'après 10 ans
de gel des quotas,
6000 places de formation
infirmière ont été ouvertes.
Il faut élargir
les compétences
des infirmiers.
C'est une réponse
qui est celle que nos concitoyens
attendent.
La présence infirmière
à proximité,
c'est pour beaucoup
le maintien à domicile
qui est assuré.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur William Martinet.
- William Martinet: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le Premier ministre,
car le président
de la République
n'a pas daigné nommer
un ministre du Logement
de plein exercice.
La vague de froid qui traverse
le pays provoque
une hécatombe.
Une femme
dans le Vaucluse,
un homme
dans les Hauts-de-Seine,
un autre dans le Val-d'Oise...
En seulement quatre jours,
trois corps gelés
ont été retrouvés
dans la rue, une cave
ou un abri de fortune.
Ces personnes
n'ont pas été tuées
par le froid.
Elles ont été tuées par la misère.
Elles sont les victimes
de votre politique.
La baisse des APL,
l'augmentation
des loyers, la casse
du logement social,
l'accélération des expulsions...
Vous êtes responsable
de ces drames humains.
On se souvient du vote
de l'infâme loi portant
le nom du député
pressenti
pour être votre ministre
du Logement.
Cette loi réprime
les sans-abri
en les condamnant à deux ans
de prison s'ils occupent
un bâtiment vide.
Vous avez fait
de la haine des pauvres
un critère pour devenir ministre.
Quelle réponse apportez-vous?
Encore et toujours la répression.
Je pense à cette institutrice
convoquée
par le rectorat
de Toulouse
pour se justifier
de son acte de solidarité
en accueillant
des enfants SDF
dans son établissement.
Vous incarnez l'égoïsme social.
Eux sont la République,
ses principes,
ses valeurs.
Ils sont la fraternité
inscrite
sur le fronton des écoles.
Honte à vous.
L'année écoulée
a été celle
de tous les records:
record des dividendes versés
aux actionnaires
du CAC 40, record
de sans-abri.
Réquisition des logements vacants!
Si vous n'en trouvez pas,
nous vous aiderons.
A quelques centaines
de mètres d'ici,
au métro Solférino,
l'association Droite
au logement campe au pied
d'un immeuble haussmannien vide.
Vous n'avez aucune excuse.
Votre inaction est coupable.
Votre politique tue.
Vous avez des comptes à rendre.
A toutes les bonnes volontés,
je dis rendez-vous
au métro Solférino
pour le droit
au logement!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu:
Monsieur le député
William Martinet, sincèrement,
j'aurais aimé que,
de la même manière
que cet hémicycle,
dans un moment de silence
qui l'honore compte tenu
de la gravité du sujet,
quand la députée Sandrine Josso
a pris la parole,
au lieu de chercher
à faire de la petite
politique
que vous cherchiez
à vous mettre
au niveau de ce moment.
Ce qui est historique
aujourd'hui,
ce sont les niveaux
d'hébergement d'urgence.
C'est plus du doublement
du nombre
de places.
Chaque soir,
ce sont 120.000 personnes
hébergées
en Ile-de-France
dans les dispositifs
d'hébergement d'urgence.
120 millions d'euros
ont été débloqués.
Depuis quelques jours,
les maraudes
se sont intensifiées.
C'est la mise en place
du plan Grand froid
dans près de 60 départements.
C'est la réquisition
de gymnases, d'écoles.
Et au milieu de ça,
vous choisissez
la polémique.
Vous choisissez
le dépôt de plainte
au lieu de soutenir,
et vous essayez
d'en faire un petit objet.
Sincèrement, dans tous
les pays d'Europe,
la question de la gestion
des sans-abri
est beaucoup trop complexe
pour en faire.
Regardez comment
nous pouvons,
avec les collectivités
locales,
avec les uns et les autres,
travailler.
Hier soir, j'étais
avec le SAMU social.
J'étais en maraude.
Je peux
vous assurer
qu'il y avait bien
plus de dignité
que dans la façon
que vous tentez
de polémiquer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La séance des questions
au gouvernement est terminée.